hi I'm Chloe Conan at developer
relations engineer here at Google and
I'm going to be taking you around the
conference floor today and show you all
the things that you can't experience
online at next but in person let's go so
this is my first Google Cloud next I'm
really excited I heard there's a bunch
of really cool booths obviously very
excited for the swag I think I'm most
excited for seeing a bunch of people in
person for the first time it's been a
really long time since I've
since I've offered so excited to see
some co-workers I'm excited to meet a
bunch of our partners and our customers
um but honestly I'm just really excited
to learn all the fun exciting Google
announcements so let's go in
thank you